[Music]
in sad times news
oh oh soon Dabashi no be no loves JK
hello Ashima be even real
a man recounts the details of losing his
family in the ongoing California
wildfires oh [ __ ] you guys heard of this
story where are the water in the bay
right or like NorCal is it those wild
flowers or cow yeah every summer we get
wildfires but they're crazy though right
now they're pretty hot yeah we're
reading yeah yeah yeah always near
reading
I swear dude that's crazy so they're
calling it the car fire with two R's car
fire this has already torched more than
121 a KERS you know there's like special
forces firefighter dudes that are out
there fighting fires like 48 hours
straight out of time
yeah my cousin was one of the like he he
was in a program that they did that to
her cousin he's old a party was the
ghost rate teams right
yeah I'm time I'll explode like they're
they're already a fighter firefighter or
whatever and then they're like another
elite person that they carry like a
chainsaw guys have to cut [ __ ] all the
time there's a sad story there's made a
movie about a whole group of those guys
was like 19 of them and they all died
fighting fighting one fire yeah I'm just
trying to protect us - was it the fire
we just went through last year no this
is you know what's intense you know why
cuz like we you know how we've been in a
drought right so for the longest time I
live where's the water we need the water
and in one season we had so much [ __ ]
rain and everyone was like yes green
forest awesome and then we had those
fires dude in the 405 was lit up yeah
gosh it was she looked like a movie so
the car fire have already killed at
least six people is it the name in the
city town or I just know that that's
what they're calling I don't know that's
the point of this sad time so we'll try
I guess we're trying to figure out
I'm sure get ready I'm gonna beat fire
so in this big fire we're trying to
visualize where TIFF this big fire took
Plano home with car County all car
county okay I made that up so you guys
work feel alright forget sad so this big
fire there was this grandpa who he'll
had to leave for an appointment
he left his 70 year old wife a kind of
appointment no I'm just kidding no exact
thing the question is was it worth the
darkness was it I hope it wasn't a foot
what not here so he left a 70 year old
wife named melody and their two great
grandchildren four-year-old Emily and
five-year-old James and this is his wife
two kids she's got nice arms for all a
lady oh yeah smooth huh yeah you don't
see that what all right so now I'm going
to show you guys interview of him
retelling this oh no all right he looks
Australian it was like a gold miner here
we go it is a California went to town my
wife called me she said we can see the
fire way over there and said you need to
come and get me I said I'm on my way so
I just drove down everything took off
over there at all I got up on quartz
hill and then there's two or three four
lanes of traffic come out will let me
down in there so I just sawed off
everything and I took off running down
there and I helped some guy that was got
burnt and was trying to get out of there
I got got him and helped him out of
there and then when I got back down
there's a fire was the fire was just
intense and uh but I still tried to get
down in there and they come and stop me
wouldn't let me go down in ER so I got
my car and took off and passed everybody
in the dirt and went her all the way
around to the other end in court seal
and come up at Keswick and my son was in
there he was up there but I didn't see
him he was up there and then Gary was my
son was on the other side of the house
and Gary opened the door
go run to the house and a Bernese hair
off and took his breasts are you back in
the car and then he he couldn't even
hardly see nothing for smoke to get out
of there
his house was on fire he said as flames
placed 70 feet high
I talked to jr. on the phone till he
died he just kept saying grandpa it's a
gimme the fire's coming in the back door
come on grandpa
I said am i down root he said coming at
us and we said I love you grandpa
grandma says I love you grandpa and jr.
says I love you come and get us coming
yet as I said on my way I said he'd be
talking till he died I tried to call him
back and it just went to nothing he poor
babies and my wife so were they in the
house and then could obviously it's not
that house that burned down right so
they were trapped in the house and then
it and it just got burned down yeah and
he couldn't get to them like what what I
don't get is so you know tornadoes and
stuff there's a warning right and then
people get told to evacuate even for
fires they get told to evacuate so he's
saying that in his neighborhood no one
was told to evacuate the fire was
actually going in the opposite direction
that's why he felt like it was safe
enough to leave but then as soon as he
left like how cold was the [ __ ] I mean
winds could change yeah but it's so
heartbreaking like this story went viral
cuz I mean he lost three family members
one day so you want to know conspiracy
I don't do a [ __ ] if you want to know
I'm gonna tell you anyway alright check
this out okay
might change my mood man alright well it
kind of applies to this so it's still
sad
but okay all right all right get this
so we lost funding from the national
government because we are a state that
is like a sanctuary state right so so we
don't get funding anymore because
something about like we're not agreeing
and playing nice with the feds and every
year the way California supposedly makes
money is we arson the [ __ ] out of our
own forests so we could get funding from
the federal government like disaster
funding hey we need help we need
billions and billions of dollars because
our situation is so bad we're in so much
debt there's just so much like bleeding
of money that's happening from
government officials and stupid programs
and things like that that it sucks like
so if we could dig and figure out who
the culprits are whether it's just
stupid kids doing some pyro work or if
there's some conspiracy going on
ah I propose that we burn them I think
that cuz every year someone gets some
like some kids like do some pyro [ __ ]
our like they're like camp firing in and
you know it goes out of control that's
always that that's always the [ __ ] like
it's never like that's the reason that
they yeah
words like campfire got our controllers
and yeah yeah it's never like someone
was playing with the magnifying glass or
something like else it's always campfire
or some kids were burning some [ __ ]
wasn't it last year when the mudslides
happen in Santa Barbara or something it
was last year right kids we're [ __ ]
playing with mud no so they're saying
that the reason why the month let fly it
happen is because the bush or whatever
that would stop that yeah usually it
burns
oh yeah it's a domino effect so then now
when the rain came they were mudslides
shame an I don't know but every year
though we have these insane as fires and
I'm like hmm maybe we should tell people
to don't cap in the summer we also have
a [ __ ] ton of dry ass brush like
everywhere that's true when it gets hot
fires can happen just from the Sun yeah
that's Nature's Way of restarting in the
forest when it's super hot they shut
down the shooting ranges to discuss what
the metal casings come out they fly out
somewhere and it can like land and like
some dry leaves and start a fire under -
jeez it's just so hot that it's like
it's just a fire way and it happens they
shot all the shooting when he's down
that's why every year in July 4th
well I [ __ ] always every year but how
we came by no fireworks here I'm also
like yeah that's pretty dry up there man
when we were in Arizona like they have a
lot of controlled fires too so it always
smelled like burning wood and they were
like all around this time because it's
really [ __ ] hot like we do our own
controlled fires everywhere yes so it
already starts burning a bunch of [ __ ]
so that this [ __ ] doesn't happen hey
primo we don't do that I think we know
but it's not good enough I don't smell
it because people's house is given but
dude my parents a couple years ago well
I guess now like 10 years ago Jesus
there was a huge fire in San Diego and
then like Escondido where my whole
family basically lives and and I
remember my mom calling me I was at work
and she I was at work up in up in LA and
she calls me and she's like Steven the
fire it's it's spread to our area
because we had been like she'd been
telling us about the fire than [ __ ] and
she said it's pretty our area and your
dad he went to go fight the fire yeah he
went to go to the neighborhood that my
uncle lives at huh to help him because
they they needed to make sure that they
liked all the brush was cleared and [ __ ]
so they wouldn't hopefully catch and so
on she's like I haven't talked to him in
an hour and a half and he won't pick up
but he hasn't picked up as far as one
straight to voicemail
and so I was like oh [ __ ] like that like
so I immediately got him I left work and
I got in my car and I drove I was the
only [ __ ] driving in to San
Diego every other person was driving out
of that a fire there's no traffic and
there was there was no traffic I was the
only car it was crazy when there was
traffic on the other side I was like by
myself yeah I booked it I made it from I
made it from LA to San Diego in like 90
minutes I think was like 80 something
yeah it was crazy good eaters more in
right oh yeah it's not like on the coast
around yeah that's crazy man you could
have got an accident not even get into a
fire my mom I never gave my mom like
this my own non-dramatic Lauren yeah
yeah so so then I I go to that house
where my like where my dad was supposed
to be at and like I'm nine kidding I
park and up the hill walks my old man
looking like [ __ ] John McClane at the
end of a die hard movie like covered in
soot completely covered and hand on my
uncle single-handedly they were taking
hoses and putting them together putting
out spot fires in the whole neighborhood
because the the fire department was so
overwhelmed they basically banned in
that area it was tight
I knew [ __ ] dad you're like do anything
heroic oh but it was already done really
like I'm such a [ __ ]
yeah well I was like now I want to fight
the [ __ ] fires [ __ ] will you like can I
do something afterwards like help
somebody while they're crying or
something I paid for dinner at Denny's
that was the most heroic thing I did
that all day I wonder if there's a fire
and it's coming close to your house if
you jump in the swimming pool of it's
safe I don't think you were some people
that did that and they ended up dying
cuz you just the holes they're like this
trying to breathe yeah but that co2 in
the heat kills them off well it depends
on how close the fire is but yeah that
kids my dad's about us and my mom was a
little [ __ ] trying to you know make him
not not save all these fires
[Music]
you
[Music]